[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy
saturday we have four important playoff
games to discuss which
culminates in the meeting of two legends
tom brady
and drew brees welcome to the divisional
playoffs
edition of the squad ride presented by
draftkings
live in the bleacher report app my name
is cabbie richards and the legends who i
ride with every week
start with our betting expert kelly
stewart and if he's gonna dance on some
logos he's bringing
winners only please that is greg ivory
we've been on any time touchdowns on
this show so salute to stefan diggs
who had the bills mafia in a frenzy last
week he caught a touchdown for us
cashed the squad ride we improved to 13
and five
hey shout out to spencer freeman for the
pick much appreciated sir
the squad ride becomes harder and harder
each week because the players
are elite but there are less of them
playing each week
so earlier this either way earlier this
week on social we
asked you to drop your pick to score a
touchdown in the divisional round
and this list is outstanding as always i
like that travis kelsey is back in the
mix
you know five tight ends scored
touchdowns last week so
that's not a bad pick we have five
legendary videos to show you and one of
them
will be our squad ride in the divisional
playoff round
but first if you guys don't come correct
in the comments
greg ivory you have my permission to
slide
g-money do your thing homie cabbie
kelly you guys are telling me it's time
it is time you guys know what this is it
is back from the er
back from the er got it back
the handy dandy ipad is back i got um
skn k hunt for 200 is saying
kill kelsey and bell
touchdowns shouts out to you you're
walking away with a hoodie
i got silk sick oracle sand 13-5
clapping his hands yes thank you for
shouting out our record
you're also rocking walking away with a
hoodie
oh my god they call me gregalicious
let's get this money
okay okay wait time up guys
time out just getting some love that's a
technical
that is a technical you're not walking
away with a hoodie but for that
but beer 410 says diggs is about to go
off
he's gonna get a hoodie all right that's
it cabbie let's go
okay well let's go off let's get this
tournament started
we have some videos they go face to face
you know how this works
so we are going to start with loge mabry
is our first pitch
logan who you got scoring a touchdown
what's going on br betting anytime td
squirrel
we're going with josh allen buffalo
bills baby bills mafia
gimme winners only gimme winners only
gimme winners only bill's mafia josh
allen anytime td scored let's go
before i congratulate the bill's mafia
greg i know you're gonna
there might be a violation on the play
but congrats bill's mafia for winning
your first playoff game
since playstation one shout out to ssx
and and crashes and the creaky gabby the
best game ever
yes it was it was legit all right your
next opponent is
anox 99 who do you got for us homie
all right boys we're going for a nice
dig find the lock of the week
oh what's this
[Music]
stefan diggs anytime sunshine score
while we're going digging
i think it's a sign walking then
stefan diggs was a diamond in the rough
drafted in the fifth round in 2015.
well done homie so g-money we have
teammates
josh allen and stefan diggs in the
opening matchup
what'd you like about these videos
cabbie
the first one we have to address it we
have to address it
we do yeah it's another technical we're
it's
we're in the show we're we just started
and we got two t's already
we got two t's already the technical
buddy it's winners only please please
say the police
let's talk about let's talk about the
video though cabbie i like the pic but
the video could use
just a little bit more uh creativity i
feel like my guy
had to sneak to the car you know do the
video
so his girlfriend would know he he
wasn't he was like you know that he's
not
that he's betting her i don't even know
what i'm trying to say but
he snuck to the car yeah he snuck to the
car because his girlfriend
knows that he's not supposed to be
betting yet anyway moving on to the
other guy
i'm just impressed that like i've been
try whenever i try to grow something
it lasts for like two days whenever i
try to plant something in the earth
it lasts only for two days my guy's
sitting here growing
locks growing locks in the soil cabbie
but we got teammates here we got
teammates the buffalo bills is facing
off against the baltimore ravens it's
going to be a
battle in buffalo uh supposedly supposed
to be snowing the last time i heard
so kelly talk to me we got teammates
here josh allen sitting at plus money
stefan diggs also sitting at plus money
which way are you riding which way are
you leaning
you know what greg you nailed it i think
this is going to be a really good game
and i don't want to give away too much
because you gotta wait to the end of the
show to see what my best bet is but if
you're a buffalo fan or a buffalo better
these prices kind of scare me stefan
diggs
one of the best receivers in the
playoffs right now is plus 110.
eek that is scary if you're going to
force me to pick i'm going to take diggs
even though i do think that this ravens
defense will be able to stifle him
somewhat
somewhat look what we saw with them due
last week
to derrick henry that being said you're
right
dude and log is that what you called him
cabbie
low got a technical he didn't even say
the please
so we'll go with uh the dig legend here
and stuff kelly's catching on kelly's
catching on please say the please
i'm back into the comments i'm back into
the comments
whoa whoa whoa all right so the
firefighters are here guys
firefighters are in the comments
firefighters m-e-n-c
greg you're the men and they're also
riding uh i saw them they're riding with
us
stefan diggs moving on so shouts out to
you guys the firefighters you guys are
walking away
with a hoodie i got kp giant sand
imagine not taking digs
could it be me shouts out to you kp
giants you're also walking away with a
hoodie
johnny just threw one out there cabbie
and i'm just gonna say it because it's a
good take
he said under on both games today
kelly you might have a take on that but
he johnny hoes just threw one out there
he set the under on both games today
shout out to you johnny you're walking
away with a hoodie cabbie next one i'm
rocking and rolling with
i got siraj144 diggs is five
words l-o-c-k five words
winners only uh i don't know what five
words mean
one word was lock who's yeah that's four
letters and then
winners only there's no plea so please
yeah we're going to give him a we're
we're going to give him a c for
effort but since but since it's me but
since it's me
and since we're here to give away
hoodies hey you're walking away with a
hoodie buddy
uh cabbie it's apparent it is apparent
stefan diggs
in the dig legend is moving on
to the next round all right well shout
out to a knox 99 and stefan diggs
for making out of the first quarter of
the three quarters less left
so let's keep this bad boy going our
next opponent
is eminem i am
and david blaine you are not
alvin kamara anytime touchdown score
lock it in
eminem i am you may not be david blaine
or the incredible bert wonderstone but
alum kamara makes magic happen and
actually was
pretty impressive g-money what'd you
think about this latest video
cabbie the the the most impressive thing
about the video
isn't the car trick it isn't the way he
catches it
it's actually uh
the fact that this man knows how to use
the slow motion
effect on the iphone like i still
haven't figured that out
i've had an iphone for like i don't know
more than half of my life
and i still haven't figured that out
kelly i know you be on your phone all
the time you might
know how to you know flip on the
slow-motion uh filter or not
but uh let's talk about the pick let's
talk about the pick we got alvin kamara
sitting at -200 stefan diggs plus
money kelly you know numbers you know
value talk to me
please talk to me alvin kamara minus 200
stephon diggs
plus money which way are you leaning
well alvin kamara's already faced this
bucks team
twice this year week one and week nine
week one
we were on the saints week nine i knew
that my bucks ticket was a loser before
that game even kicked off on a monday
night the second
i gave it out i saw the show i said we
already got a loser
don't bet it i'm so sorry that being
said i'm not gonna make that mistake
again
and take a chance here on the bucks
against a team that has their number
and that is the new orleans saints and
alvin kamara kamara scores
two touchdowns they should give us a
better odds missing three to one here
at draftkings greg because our dude is
going off against the bucks
was that a tonight lock kelly just gave
us a height lock
was that a tonight lock that might be a
tonight tonight lot tonight live
yeah anyway i'm in the comments i am in
the comments bin
i got ben uh s-o-n-k 6-1-9
i think he's rocking with alvin kamara
he says winners only please shout out to
you ben
you're walking away with a hoodie uh i
got i got
hip ion i l is10 i i i i couldn't say
that one but he said kamara
all the way kamara all the way shouts
out to you you're walking away with a
hoodie
uh cabbie brett stevens said if camaro
doesn't score please don't give me my
hoodie i don't want it
there i like hey i'm i'm okay all right
brett i'm gonna leave you to that right
now i'm gonna give you a hoodie but if
he doesn't score
you said it buddy uh cabbie i mean if
you look at the comments it's pretty
apparent it is pretty apparent alvin
kamara
is literally walking away with this one
i got one more in bar
gs kamara about to re repeat week 16.
i believe so cabbie moving on to the
next round we have the magic
legend and alvin kamara
uh they're moving on man the comment
said so
if memory serves me correctly week 16 is
when he scored
six touchdowns on christmas day so if it
was a repeat of that oof
that's blowing the doors off the tampa
bay bucks hey congratulations to emma
eminem i am the magic legend and alvin
kamar the magic number is two you have
to beat two more opponents
to be our squad ride in the divisional
round so let's get to round three
our next pitch comes from leo cunningham
who you got scoring a touchdown today
homie
i boys report they want to easy lock my
boy leo's got it right here
you've got devonta adams anytime
i got two questions i got two questions
okay what time of the day
was this video filmed and why was it 1
19 a.m
and have you ever seen such healthy
munchies
when you are craving uh those late night
eats
have either of you guys of what are
those what are those
get in the comment all right captain
hold on i might get the audience
involved get in the comments and tell me
who these two look like
who do these two look like who these two
remind you of uh
i don't know what's higher cabbie and
kelly i don't know what's higher
uh these dudes are the likelihood of
devontae adams
actually scoring a touchdown i really
i don't know what's higher but uh with
that being said
let's let's talk about the pick let's
talk about the pick devonte adams uh
he's been balling leading
the league in receiving touchdowns you
know he knows the end
zone kelly and cabbie uh they're both
you know we got almost a buck 50
favorite with
adams and we got two bills over there
with kamara kelly you know numbers
you know value talk to the people which
way are you leaning where do you see the
value in these two
uh picks you know this is tough because
i know cabbie is our resident packers
fan and i love devonte adams i think he
is
such a good wide receiver and he makes
noise on the field
not in the pressers so he's more
exciting to watch
for me but he is facing jalen ramsey
today
and that scares the ever living bejesus
out of me because
jaylen ramsey's one of the best
defensive backs and we had a thing on br
gridiron the other day that showed
what jalen ramsay was able to do as a
knock down corner
i think our buddy ocho cinco had some
things to say about it as well that
scares me i do like the packers in a
teaser
i tease them down to a half but as far
as the pick goes
we gotta go with kamara draftkings is
gonna give us three to one on alvin
kamara
i just think this is a no-brainer
kelly thinks it's a no-brainer in the
comments they're all over the two guys
i got uh va for life three says they
look like ren
and stimpy uh i got um
dog goo hey says these dudes look like
jay and silent bob yes
[Laughter]
i mean one dude is about a hundred
pounds slimmer uh excellent
shouts out to you guys shouts out to you
guys both of you guys are walking away
woody i can keep on going on and on
but let me actually get some pics in
here uh scooby drew says
aaron drones baby shouts out to you
scooby drew
uh ben ben man 56 said he's not liking
devonta
adams against ramsey he's not liking
devante adams against ramsey he might
have a point there
cabbie the next one i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna decide
uh here we go slide slide
hit here we go i got uh alvin kamara
here alvin kamara
ben sonk 619. he's rocking with alvin
kamara
uh shouts out to you bro you're walking
away with a hoodie cabbie it's apparent
the people
have spoken we are riding with alvin
kamara and the magic legend
moving on to the next round okay wow
well done
eminem i am the magic legend with alvin
kamara moving into the final round
this final matchup decides our squad
ride in the divisional
playoffs so let's get it our final pitch
comes from oscar 19 parkinson this
legend returns
and he's chipping away at greatness
aaron jones baby ah
he's got that lovely pga music in the
background there
well done tell us in the comments
whether you like alvin kamara
or aaron jones to be the squad ride
g-money what'd you think about
oscar 19 peterson's return rowing a
curveball here cabbie throwing a
curveball i need the comments to tell me
their best pga course okay
meet it in the comments your best pga
course in the comments giving away
hoodies
greg your favorite pga course
[Music]
top golf the one in napa the one in napa
kelly the safeway open
the safeway no no that's that's the
other place what a nap
it's the safeway open it's up uh
silverado yeah
google it that's that's that's my
favorite i worked there before that's
why i said that
but anyway here we go let's talk about
the video let's talk about the video of
my guy looked like a natural he was a
calm and confident
uh reminds me of the time i beat kelly
at topgolf you know when she plays
every week she's literally on the golf
course every week and it was my first
time playing you know i went out there
like a natural and
beat her uh but yeah that's what this
guy reminded me of let's talk about the
pick if they're inside the five kelly
and kathy if the packers are
inside the five you're going to see a
heavy dose of aaron jones
you're going to see a heavy dope so i
like the chances of him scoring a
touchdown
today i like the chances of him scoring
touchdown today but kelly
talk to me you know numbers you know
value alvin kamara aaron jones
who are you riding with you know greg
you're right if they are inside the five
i do think we will see an aaron jones
touchdown
i just have my concerns with this rams
pass rush
and what they're going to be able to do
in to this packers team
that being said if there's a heavy pass
rush they're going to be running the
ball
look i just think it's just a no-brainer
to take kamara here i've been saying
this all show it's the easy pick and
they're going to give us three to one
again i don't i don't love the packers
today i'm definitely
not laying the seven i don't know if i'm
gonna get to the window with the rams
i just need the packers to win the game
i just need the saints to
put on a show under our dude alvin
kamara
okay well get in the comments and let us
know which way you're riding alvin
kamara or aaron jones
in the meantime one of the a few of the
trends that i've noticed
when kelly stewart gives out her best
bet is a
they win a lot and b she likes underdogs
so at this time kelly stewart give the
people what they want who
is your best bet in the divisional
playoff round
cabbie you know i love underdogs because
they always have a shot to win
outright i love that plus money that's
what i'm really addicted to here
and i think that they never get a lot of
love it's so easy just to lay seven with
some favorite that being said
you only have to take two and a half
this is a baby underdog today we're
going to take the ravens
at the bills now i know a lot of it has
been made about the weather greg
commented on that as well
i don't think this baltimore ravens team
is the team coming from miami and should
be concerned here
i know the bills have been red-hot and
they have been absolutely on fire but we
finally saw that come to an end
with the colts last week i hope the
colts defensive game plan
is something that harbaugh is going to
take because if they can shut down
diggs and stifle josh allen the
baltimore ravens can win this game
why because the bills can't stop the run
so we already know
that the ravens are gonna be able to run
all over this field
ravens plus two ravens on the money line
and don't forget
just add them to one of your teasers
plus eight and a half gotcha
yes you mentioned that earlier you have
uh the green bay packers
you teased them down to half a point and
the baltimore ravens you teased them up
to eight plus eight and a half correct
kells
yes that is correct i might follow that
yeah it's
yeah i might too uh listen baltimore's
defense held
derrick henry to 40 yards last week and
you know lamar jackson
when he freestyles or he scrambles he is
he can run all over the field so get on
draftkings
lock in baltimore plus two and a half or
plus three
whatever whatever is uh the most current
odds if you're following
our mvp kelly stewart because g money
and i are
riding right here at this moment
i know there's some joy in your fingers
you have the answer to our question
who is our squad ride in the divisional
round
aaron jones or alvin kamara give it to
us please
[Applause]
cabbie kelly
i'm in the handy dandy ipad into the
comments nt
kwame says rams will focus on devonta
and aaron jones
tie-in to score as a lock winners only
please my guy just came in just dropping
takes
has nothing to do with who's going to
win but anyway
uh i got c ziegler says kamara
easily getting the w minimum two
touchdowns
shout out to uc ziegler you're walking
away with a hoodie
uh i got c cline san
san kamara is a lock
evan nissan saying kamara is a lock
hp 09 says kamara is a lock and he's
also
dropping the sunset emoji
but hold on cabbie hold on i i is this
something in me it's just something in
me that just wants to scroll and
whatever i land on we're gonna ride with
okay
bro it sounds like kamara's running away
with this one it sounds like it cabbie
but
let me scroll it's all in the scroll you
gotta trust the scroll okay
trust the scroll here we go scroll
scroll bam got it
i got it right here kevin you ready for
it
you might be surprised by this one but
h-p-i-n-i-l-i-s-10 says
jones does not miss so that means one
thing shouts out to you you're walking
away with a hoodie you were walking away
he also said
jones is scoring three tds i love the
confidence
love the confidence guess what that
means guys
i'm making the decision we are riding
with aaron jones to score a touchdown
today shout out to my guy hp
in the comments i scrolled and he he
said it cabbie i scrolled and he said it
can i please see the graphics so i can
show you guys something
let me show you guys something that we
here on the squad ride can do
and that's only you see that it says
aaron jones -106
can we please change the graphic change
the graphic please there it is
odds boost just went up the odds boost
have just went up plus 300
with aaron jones uh make sure you guys
come on over to the br
instagram story where we will be riding
aaron jones two-story touchdowns
sending your videos get on the stories
but remember i need you guys to
tell me finish it off in the comments
and i'm giving away some hoodies you
know we had that was an
m night shyamalan twist there i thought
everybody was riding with kelly
kamara kamara kamara scored a couple of
touchdowns and then boom so
we're rocking with aaron jones that's
what the squad wants
greg scrolls landed on aaron jones so
uh follow our br betting uh social story
because g money is is hella entertaining
on
on a football weekend thank you for
everybody who commented
shout out to the legends logan mabry
oscar 19 peterson a knox 99 leo
cunningham
and eminem i am we are back on sunday
on sunday for the conference
championship games and also we have a
very special surprise
show planned for uh monday january the
25th monday january the 25th
a surprise show look out for that
announcement you don't want to miss it
because it's
huge cabbie all right yes craig
do not mean to cut you off but the
comments are uh the comments are
still on fire they're on me man they're
they're sad they
they said i brought bad vibes because we
we we went with eric jones but that is
okay because i'm giving out hoodies
b smith 34 winners only please you're
good walking away with hoodie
uh trey 23 winners only please you're
walking away with a hoodie
uh here we go still in the comments uh
just one more greg we got to save them
for our special actually their
albert's final show on sunday i'm not
giving away i'm not giving away anymore
you gotta get here okay they're they're
they're mad at me bro they're mad at it
it's okay thank you okay listen feel
free to slime them like we're on
nickelodeon
uh alongside kelly stewart and greg
ivory my name is cabby richards thank
you for rocking with
us this has been the squad ride good
luck with your wagers and peace
[Music]
you